a new documentary gives us an inside
look at the work life of one of
America's most powerful women Pelosi in
the house follows a career of house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi from her early
years in Congress to becoming second in
line to the presidency the person behind
the lens is Pelosi's own daughter her
youngest documentary filmmaker Alexandra
Pelosi who was given extraordinary
access including on January 6 when she
and her mother were evacuated from the
capitol the speaker remained hard at
work even as rioters tried to hunt her
down
all right Mr Vice President
hi yeah we're okay we're here with Mr
Schumer Mr McConnell the leadership
House and Senate and uh how are you
oh my goodness where are you
God bless you
but are you in a very safe
very special well that we're still not
safe enough for us to go back we're
being told it could take days to clear
the capital and that we should be moving
away with everyone who has got the job
done uh we're at Fort McNair which has
facilities for the house and the Senate
to meet we'd rather go to the Capitol
and do it there but it doesn't seem to
be safe
and Alexandra Pelosi joins us now
Alexandra good morning
um thank you for being here thank you
for having me the documentary is
fantastic it's incredibly engaging it
covers it packs in her whole life in 140
in an hour and 45 minutes it is non-stop
watchable television for sure it's also
tough because we're at a tough moment in
this country uh and we saw a clip there
from January 6th your father in the
aftermath of January 6 attacked recently
so I want to start just a lot of our
viewers will be wondering I know you
said he's doing okay physically how is
he doing emotionally and how's your
family doing
well it's really long term this isn't
sort of like the flu that you get over
he's physically healing every day and he
has great doctors but the bigger
conversation is about how you recover
from something that's traumatic I mean
it's really traumatic but also then we
go to the conversation of how did we end
up here you know these threats have been
there for decades hundreds of millions
of dollars have been spent
to demonize Nancy Pelosi over the years
and she's always had protection right
but the rest of us have always been
rather exposed and always sort of felt
this vulnerability this was sort of like
everybody's worst nightmare and then it
actually came true so for us we're still
trying to make peace with the fact that
you know I am not a card-caring member
of the democratic party I'm not walking
or I'm not a political person you know
all the films I've been making over the
years I'm not a political person I
really don't care who you vote for but I
really do think that the toxic political
landscape that we're living in right now
is it's so hard to make peace with the
fact that just because you sign up to go
run for office someone's going to break
into your house and attack your husband
I mean that's really a lot yeah it was
inconceivable when it happened there's a
line in the documentary where you ask
your mom how do you make peace with the
fact that because of the work you do
people want to kill you she says I have
my faith I didn't choose this job this
job chose me how do you make peace with
the fact that because of the work that
she does people want to kill your mother
there I mean It's haunting to me when to
be her daughter when they're going Nancy
Pelosi the way they were doing it is
chilling Alex how do you make peace with
it well I don't I'm not I mean it's it's
really sort of a sad reflection of where
we've come it's what social media has
done to this country it's really
destroying the fabric of our culture but
these threats have been there for a long
time because there's a whole political
industrial complex that went and turned
my last name into a curse word so
they've been destroyed I mean the amount
of misogyny that's gone into this over
the decades
that's really something that's hard to
make peace with because if there are
people my mother's always taught us
public service is a noble calling she
believes that public service is a noble
calling yeah I would not I would not
wish this on my worst enemy I would
never let if somebody came to me and
said I'm thinking of running for public
office I'd say you're insane do you have
any idea what kind of a risk you're
exposing to yourself and your family to
yeah you say be careful um there's a
moment in this film where you tell your
mom she's a tough nut to crack
um which and she is amazing scenes yeah
and listen that's saying a lot because
politics at times can be nuts um but
what did you learn about your mother
while filming well here's the thing
she's not gay on those this you've tried
you've tried to crack her right she
doesn't she's not an overshare she's not
an animal we're trying to crack her I
was just trying to get her to open it up
yeah she doesn't spread it on the couch
and over share yeah like I do you know
it's just a different so
some people think there's going to be
this sort of other side you know this
sort of like right and it doesn't exist
and so that's why you have to people in
public life right you have this don't
you where you have to be a certain way
you have to be on your best behavior in
public and then you go home maybe when
you get home I don't know how you are
how are you at home I do get undressed
I'm not walking around in high heels
yeah right see so that's who she is it's
in her DNA she believes in this stuff so
this is if you try and ask her about it
it's not like she's going to come home
and say she's she's on message because
she's on a mission but you know the
phone was also full of behind the scenes
moments not at home but in her office
with her staff in the aftermath of
historic events plotting the strategy uh
to get done what she got done and that's
what makes the movie so incredible your
access uh and your sensitivities as her
daughter yeah so I was never actually
given permission let's be sorry about
one thing there are some people that are
going to be very upset when this movie
comes out starting probably with Nancy
Lucy in the house comes out on HBO
tomorrow Alexandra thank you very much
very good very good